Vous mettez le dentifrice avant ou après avoir mouillé votre brosse à dent?
Y'a une réglementation pour ça?
Est-ce que quelqu'un sait ce qu'il faut faire?
Non?
Oui, bon d'accord, je m'invente un petit peu des problèmes, surtout qu'aujourd'hui
je vais vous parler de séries
Donc rien à voir
Je vais vous parler de séries américaines
C'est pas que j'aime pas les séries françaises ....
Non...
Attention commissaire
Huh?! Quoi?
Vous avez un truc là.
Ah! Merci
SUPER!
C'est vrai que quand tu t'ennuies un petit peu, une bonne série, franchement ça t'occupes bien
Par contre je me suis un peu imposé une règle à moi-même:
Ne jamais commencer une série!
Les américains font des séries avec beaucoup trop de saisons
comme ça et euh...
Je sais pas... Arrêtez!
Tiens, et si je regardais Lost?
D'ailleurs c'est tellement simple de regarder des séries aujourd'hui
Hop, tu télécharges en quelques clics, toute une saison.
Stop stop attendez attention!
Je ne télécharge pas, ah non!
J'achète les DVD
Vous n'avez rien vu....
Vous avez tout oublié
Vous mettez votre dentifrice avant de mouiller votre brosse à dent
Alors moi les séries américaines j'adore ça!
Par contre, il y a un petit truc qui me chiffonne:
Les scénaristes partent un petit peu en sucette quoi
Exemple:
Dans la première saison de Prison Break
Y a un des personnages à qui on coupe la tête
et qui revient dans les saisons d'après
Les scénaristes se sont quand même dit:
Ça passe tout seul
Salut ça va?  Ça fait longtemps! Qu'est-ce que tu deviens?
Oh! Ca? La tête? Ah nan, c'est rien du tout t'inquiète pas
J'ai mis un peu de scotch, de la patience, et c'est réglé
Y'a juste la tête qui tombe un petit peu
Mais c'est un détail
Aucun problème
Normal
Le problème c'est qu'en France on ne peut pas parler de séries. C'est un sujet tabou.
Pour une raison simple, c'est pour éviter ça:
Ah...la la,  quand Jack quitte Liv pour se marier avec le Docteur Shepherd
C'est incroyable comme fin quoi
Qui pouvait... Qui...
Pourquoi tu me regardes comme ça?
J'ai dit un truc qu'il ne fallait pas?
Toi aussi tu regardes des séries ?
Mais c'est trop génial !
Alors tu peux partager ma vidéo sur Facebook et rejoindre ma page! Waouh!
Tant de points communs, j'ai envie de te dire:  Vas sur cyprien.fr pour voir toutes mes autres vidéos.
C'est tout.